si la parole est à monsieur georges
fenech vous remercie monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
et j'y associe mon collègue alain
marsaud monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez récemment dénoncé est encore à
l'instant et à juste titre l' influence
néfaste d'un courant salafiste radical
d'un autre pays
certes minoritaire mais qui rencontrent
un écho important est inquiétant auprès
des jeunes ce qui dans un contexte élevé
de menace terroriste
évidemment ne peut pas nous laisser
indifférents à cet égard vous n'y aurait
pas non plus que la prison reste un lieu
privilégié de cette radicalisation
or nous apprenons avec stupéfaction et
cela m'a encore été confirmée par notre
collègue olivier falorni pas plus tard
qu'hier qu'il existe au sein du centre
pénitentiaire de saint martin de ré une
mosquée salafistes clandestine abrité
dans un baraquement dénommé en
trompe-l'oeil casino et comportant au
fronton une inscription en langue arabe
comment peut-on monsieur le premier
ministre tolérer que des discours
salafistes s'organise avec la
bénédiction si j'ose dire de
l'administration pénitentiaire c'est
invraisemblable des missions de l'état
avait déjà été soulevée par le même
olivier falorni auprès de christiane
taubira en octobre 2015 et l'ancien
garde des sceaux avait promis d'y mettre
un terme
or vérification faite ce matin sept
mosquées salafistes clandestine officie
toujours auprès des détenus du centre
pénitentiaire de saint martin de ré à
moins que vous n'ayez anticipé ce matin
ma question et je m'en réjouirai alors
s'agit-il d'un problème budgétaire de la
justice exsangue si l'on en croit les
cris d'orfraie du garde des sceaux
monsieur revol dans la presse de ce
week-end qui empêche de détruire cette
mosquée alors ma question est simple
monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous faire cesser sans délai cette
insupportable complicité passive du
système pénitentiaire lequel de surcroît
vient de supprimer de manière si merci
la parole est à monsieur jean marie le
guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
fennecs oui monsieur le député vous avez
raison la maison centrale de saint
martin de ré a été atteint par des
phénomènes de radicalisation au sein
d'un certain nombre de préfabriqués
bâtiment et vous avez raison de dire que
le député olivier falorni à saisir le
garde des sceaux et celui ci lui a
répondu tout à fait rapidement
nous considérons que ce problème des
jeux c'est préfabriqué a été traité ils
ont été fermés monsieur le député par la
nouvelle directrice de cet établissement
et d'ailleurs nous avons débloqué 26
millions d'euros sur trois ans qui ont
été engagés pour financer ces travaux de
réhabilitation le chantier commencera
fin 2016 aura un an et les préfabriqués
les préfabriqués seront détruits à cette
occasion comme vous le voyez
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a rien
à cacher le garde des sceaux tient que
je tu veux excuser qui comme vous le
savez est retenu aujourd'hui au sénat je
tiens à vous assurer de son entière
détermination à lutter contre la
radicalisation dans le cadre du plan
proposé par le premier ministre tous les
personnels pénitentiaires ont été formés
à cette dimension de l'action de leur
métier fin 2016 60 aumônier
supplémentaires ont été recrutés grâce
aux renseignements pénitentiaire
monsieur le député marceau le repérage
des personnes radicaliser leur prise en
charge notamment de cinq unités dédiées
arts a été renforcée et donc ne douter
ni de notre volonté de lutter contre la
radicalisation ni de notre volonté de
transparence
merci la parole est à monsieur guide